again today
good afternoon councilors staff members
of the public welcome along to this
meeting of the community well-being
committee
I have no apologies
are there any Declarations of Interest
if not we'll move straight into the
public forum
no welcome along
you know the seat you've got a choice of
two
once again Noel you know you've got 10
minutes to present if you want to use
all that time yourself that's fine
otherwise if you'd like counselors to
have some time to ask questions
I am
probably won't be in the whole 10
minutes
um speaking because I have provided some
supplementary material which you
made out here and uh I think it's
actually well time that I'm presenting
it now because it's my Christmas present
to you
um you'll have lots of time over
Christmas to um
go into it it's quite complex and it's
it's actually just a
a sort of snapshot of what's going on
with climate change it's not the total
thing in fact every day
there's new information coming forward
that um really needs to be paid
attention to
and and if it's any help I've actually
created a Facebook page called climate
I hope you don't use
um Facebook or bad luck or borrow
somebody else's
um but I'm ongoingly voluntarily keeping
a timeline up to date with what's
actually happening
um a lot of it's Global picture it's not
just what's happening in New Zealand
I I think that um if you could focus on
this
um picture that I've got right at the
top and the beginning a low-carbon
economy what's the hold up
and if if we um take off the masks and
and uh you know start to really look at
what the issue is and and how serious it
is and what the problem is
instead of kicking the can down the road
and we'll Etsy make some progress and I
met you here to try and be helpful and
to initiate some discussion within
councils and I don't mean
just in the kaggle city council and I'm
hoping to go and speak to all the
councils
including the Regional Council but as
you see
in my comments here you'll see there
could well be a unitary Council in the
future
so it's it is all about working together
it's all very much about working as a
team
um I I do think um
seriously that um it in the we need to
start investing some serious money
in this whole climate change matter
it's a crisis
the other word for a crisis is an
emergency
the nation the Prime Minister declared
it as an emergency two years ago
and we're still barely mentioning it
here in council chambers so
I I think it's something that we need to
put serious money into and if the longer
you leave it and the more I'm serious
it's going to be and the more money it's
going to cost and and instead of um
having nice to have projects spending
tens of millions and we've got to start
looking at spending some Millions if not
tens of Millions
on climate mitigation and and uh
climate adaptation and resilience and
interestingly I see there's some people
here today that are going to speak to
you about food resilience about having
resilience in their local community and
you know it's at a dangerous Point
there's not a lot of people actually
growing food here and it instead of
having some crumbs off the council table
and that in this particular subject
needs to have some proper investment
um I'll I'll leave it there
um open to questions
thanks Noel Tom
[Music]
no look that this whole subject is like
an elephant nobody knows quite how you
grab it right and when you I mean it's
it's it's so big I mean if if you could
advocate for the council doing just one
thing at the moment
who would it be a planet
no I know but I mean climate change is
the the elephant I'm talking about yeah
within that what would you what would
you have us do if we could only do one
thing as I've said um in this document
I'm looking at a climate education hub
um as an online Hub and there's a
Roadshow and the Roadshow I would
suspect would go to the schools
um and teach the younger people because
the future is on the young people and
like you know I've been involved in this
climate elephant
um for over 50 years
you know I started way back in the 1970s
when we shouldn't even talk about it and
and I I think that we're actually
getting a um a grasp on a um councilor
Campbell
um if you start looking at some of the
information that I presented here you'll
see that
um people are actually getting a handle
on it there's a huge big movement
happening around the world and uh you
know I bet he said yes to certain things
that the council could do directly as as
um you know convert your Fleet your
vehicle Fleet to full Electric in like
six months ago I was told that you're
looking at getting hybrids well you know
there's no point in having a foot in the
fossil fuel puddle and another foot in
the electric puddle you need to actually
um
stick to it and go to full electric
hydrogen some years away so it won't
happen straight away
um and and you know
convert all your Parks equipment to
um electric and I I did see in the last
agenda for the risk and insurance
committee that they've been quite a
saving and they bought some electric
mowers and so it's like a little
electric buggies on that that's great
but it needs to happen faster and they
need to be uh you know
um electric because the last time I went
to Queen's Park a month ago there was a
15 horsepower mower going around mowing
grass it didn't need to be made and the
guy with a petrol blame blowing leaves
around that doesn't need to be blown
around the fact they were petals from
the from the players and like you know
you need to see it an example and and
then by the time you had rolled your
vehicles over in three years time you've
got a fleet of vehicles you can sell for
the community
thank you
that's that's just a smudging of what
I'll be talking then
bring
uh three questions uh first one this
one's yes or no question
um do you think electric vehicles should
pay radius attacks yes
okay second question uh are you happy
buying something that's perceived to be
emission free yet it's made in a country
that uses Coal Fired power to drive its
whole industry
eight years because the uh the benefit
of an electric car even if it's powered
by coal-fired electricity it's far
better than using fossil fuels
okay and do you believe that spending
millions of dollars on this
um feel good project
comes ahead of the welfare of the people
in invercargill that are struggling to
pay power bills struggling to feed
themselves I I don't think this is a
feel-good project I think no no no no no
no forget about the feel good part yeah
ask answer the question
[Music]
okay more so than feeding people and
giving them well you know as I've just
said um you know if you give the Murray
hickey Collective a decent amount of
money so that people can actually grow
gardens and grow their own food
um we'd be on the right Road the two
were intertwined well thank you for not
answering the question yeah Barry uh no
but what are those what's going to
happen with all these electric vehicles
once the batteries go what do you do
with those okay um what actually happens
with electric vehicle batteries as they
actually become storage batteries for um
solar units and or wind power units and
houses
and they can do quite a few decades um
in that position and then if you um do a
little bit of homework on the internet
you'll discover that
um in the areas where there's already
batteries being collected where there's
High populations they're actually being
reprocessed in the 99
um reuse of all the materials that come
out of those batteries and they've
actually designed the circular economy
for electric car batteries so that
um you know even here in New Zealand
when we have enough of them the process
well then they'd get chipped off but
that's you know a couple of decades if
not more away what why isn't why is the
paddocks of them overseas that people
have just dropped in The Paddock and
left them oh that's that's it to your
falsehood um you're talking about in
France there's um some electric cars
that were left in the well stored in a
paddock
um that was actually because the company
went broke it was nothing to do with the
batteries all the cows and they've
actually since been refurbished and
reused and my next point is where are we
going to get the pair to pair all these
words
um you know you're okay enough now yeah
invercargill without electricity
um a year ago
um Etsy came to your Council and and uh
and I was actually involved in that
there was a photograph of me involved in
it saying that um you know even if um we
had a doubling in the increase of demand
for electricity here in invercargill and
we're quite secure so you know and and
there will be there's a downstream
program that you're going to see coming
of um wind power and solar energy and
that's going to provide that just just
one more thing no sorry counselor okay
I'm not going to get into an EV debate
we're talking about climate change as a
whole and actually we're at time the
presentation thanks Norm uh thanks for
circulating the information prior to
coming along no I think of your passion
let me also remind you that from a local
government perspective environment
Southland are taking the lead on this uh
we're actually participating in that as
well so I think it's also very important
that you you have it yeah yeah I'm quite
aware that um councilman I'm going to go
and speak to them next year and and at
the moment they're into the logistics of
all that Downstream stuff that's going
to come from central government
um and like the NIH T out doing the the
promotional stuff and and then in my
document you'll see that my argument for
the city council doing the promotional
is that this is where the majority of
the population is and and and you guys
already have a rapport with the
community and you're the springboard
between the community the point is in
your paper thank you for that
foreign
welcome along
it's been a while actually
welcome back to the table
uh Bridget's representing the Cancer
Society and addressing us about new
resources on ultraviolet radiation
Timely
yeah today's good weather for isn't it
27 degrees
so I've actually got some things
um to give to you physically give to you
and I don't have my um panya and Evelyn
I don't have printouts for you but I'd
be very happy to email them I'll be
emailing all their Council I also have
pets which I don't have ones for you but
I could totally get them for you like I
can't do that
um so I'll just stick them here and I'm
not sure
somebody would want to hand these out to
the counselors oh so
names
um
all righty yeah
Acura I'm Bridget I'm Bridget Forsyth I
work for the Cancer Society otago
Southland division
sorry
cancels are in a unique position to
implement strategies and enable people
to live healthy active Lifestyles for
instance we acknowledge that this
Council already puts people before the
tobacco industry
by supporting the smoke-free and bakery
environments with your fabulous
smoke-free policy
today however I'm focusing on different
harm and a different cancer
the harm is excessive uvr ultraviolet
radiation and the cancerous skin cancer
which happens to be our most common
cancer
shade is an important infrastructure
issue and if we want to turn the tide on
skin cancer
we all know that we need to take
responsibility to slip slop slap and
wrap but slipping into shade is only an
option if there is some shade available
we're not suggesting everything is
covered but we are asking some Built
shade in natural shade is planned and
specifically funded for in planned
upgrades for our play spaces
aotearoa has the highest death rate for
melanoma in the world
and along with Australia we have the
highest incidents we tend to sort of
take turns at that
skin cancer is highly preventable over
90 of skin cancer is caused by too much
sun
we do need Samsung but in New Zealand we
tend to get too much
in fact here in the southern district we
have higher rates of melanoma than many
other districts in fact the age
standardized rate
per 100
000 in 2019 we were the second highest
in the country for melanoma
playgrounds are available to all parts
of our community and are especially used
by after mariki our children this makes
them a great place to invest in some
high quality shade sunburn at any age
increases the risk of melanoma but
Sunburn and childhood is particularly
risky
the more sunburns the greater the risk
our UV environment from September
through to the end of March is usually
high enough to cause damage to people
with fair skin and invercargill and UV
peaks in January we know this because
niwa have provided US 10 years of UV
index data the UV index is a measure of
the intensity of UV radiation and the
larger the number the more intense the
UV I've included this map
for each of you the World Health
Organization recommends some protection
when the UV index is three and above and
this map shows you that invercargill has
about three months 104 days to be
specific each year when the UV is uvi is
six so that's high so that's the side
with the orange
and we have on average 57 days at or
above eight which is very high you don't
have a map for that sorry
um and we have about a week's worth when
the uvi is about above 11 and that's
extreme that's the purple side
so
UV radiation increases as you get close
to the equator and that we end up with
other councils being a bit ahead of us
in terms of shade prevention provision
partly because we don't use shade to
cool ourselves down here because we
don't get the hot temperatures with it
and what people don't realize is that
the the light that we see the daylight
and the heat that we feel they're
separate from the UV we can't actually
see or feel UV and that gets really
tricky when we have cooler climates like
we do down here we can just stay outside
for ages and get way too much UV
so and that's why we can still get
sunburned on those cool and cloudy days
um appropriate shade and invercargill
will make outdoor space more comfortable
to use in all seasons and it may even
extend the life of play equipment beyond
our summer months by providing shelter
from rain
it can also be aesthetically pleasing
and it's an equity Equitable form of sun
protection and will provide for future
generations to come
strategically plant trees can also be a
good option it's usually great though if
we can have a combination of both built
and natural shade
so udv radiation can reach a person on
the ground directly from the Sun but it
can also be scattered around and
reflected by surfaces so good shade has
the good shade has the potential to
significantly reduce the UV exposure we
don't think the public should have to
choose between shade and play equipment
in a country with one of the highest
rates of skin cancer in the world
many of our schools are so smart and
many people look after their kids with
sun protection if we could have a little
more shades strategically placed where
children congregate we will reduce the
overall UV exposure UV damage builds up
over a lifetime and the damage we do in
childhood remains with us it changes our
DNA
it causes about 90 000 non-melanoma skin
cancers every year in this country on
top of the melanoma I was talking about
earlier and they all need treating
melanoma is a very aggressive cancer and
it's twice as many men die from it than
women
together with the ICC playing the part
we can turn the tide on skin cancer and
so finally I've provided with you with
that information and a sun hat that
we've made
[Music]
um to go with the information
um I'll be emailing digital versions of
that info and a link to a Nifty video
that Australia the New South Wales
Cancer Institute have put out which just
has a really good way of demonstrating
that we can't see or feel UV but it's
still there causing potential damage
um and yeah I'll email that to each of
you so if you have any questions I'll do
my best to answer those Kiana thanks
Bridget and thank you for the for the
bucket hats particularly I was just
looking at one the other day uh Ray and
then mayor Clark cheers thanks uh cheer
um my question is regarding health
worksafe and obviously I'm on the
website now looking at I've got a
section on protecting workers from solar
UV radiation now how closely do you work
with worksafe in the sense that has
anyone been has a company been
prosecuted for failing to provide their
outdoor workers which could be Builders
could be anyone could be you know if
they because obviously if you're looking
at men have twice the rate potentially
and I'm not being sexist here that mean
may have more outdoor out talking
professions yeah yeah like and so where
does how strictly
is that enforce that that I mean lawyers
look after make sure you know you've got
all the right gear and yeah I mean I
can't speak for the enforcement side of
it um I I went for a charity
um and we're not funded by this is
obviously or anything about Workforce is
a key part of yeah and people great
definitely we encourage our workplaces
too no no but I mean about this I mean I
think you're missing the point no the
question is is that obviously work with
work save have you you know I personally
haven't worked with work safe but I
wouldn't be surprised if somebody in the
cancer city around the country has
um I couldn't answer your question about
the lawsuits being taken I really enjoy
the reason I'm asking the reason
is so that the often the only way you
get people to follow the rules is
enforcement like to wear safety boots to
wear safety equipment and stuff and so
this is you're obviously saying the
serious and this and this of this means
I'm very keen to sort of spread that
messaging get people thinking about it
definitely so I was just wondering the
um how close you were with worksafe
personally I haven't worked with
worksafe closely I wouldn't be surprised
if some of my colleagues have
um
but I'm sorry I can't answer a question
it would be great to have workplaces
definitely take on board those Sun smart
messages because
you know definitely we want everyone to
be protected and to have their
workplaces provide them the best they
can to support them
so if you know anybody who works in that
space I'd be happy to talk no no I'm
keeping out of it I'm just asked the
question yeah mayor Clark and Bridget
two things I guess um one is the issue
of the um lotions that we get to slap on
I mean a lot of um
consumer affairs and others have looked
into the research that some of the stuff
that branded at plus 50 and plus 35
actually is my own figure so as you're a
society doing some work around what is
safe like the last survey I sourcing
that a brand called 365
which is um of course you may start the
warehouse I think it is and it's
actually the cheapest but it ranked the
highest of all of them yeah I think
that's because it's an australian-wide
one and we have actually been doing a
bit of work in that space currently in
Australia sunscreens are treated as a
pharmaceutical good in New Zealand
they're a cosmetic good which we think
is wrong and we've been advocating for
that to change I understand that that is
currently it's tied up in a a new
Amendment or an act that's going through
right now but it's a big Omnibus one
which has got lots of other parts in it
um and so I would be able to find out
where where we're up to with that but I
think it is going to eventually we're
going to have a place where our
sunscreens are
you're going to have to mandatorily have
to meet the certain criteria currently a
lot of the sunscreens in New Zealand
voluntarily meet the Australian New
Zealand guidelines uh personally I just
I don't recommend any above each other
if you buy this can Society ones it the
profits donate to our work but I don't
rate ours above and any others just you
know try to get one that is at least SPF
50 broad spectrum and when they're
meeting the testing requirements I know
that an SBF 51 to get to meet that
criteria on the mandatory ones it
actually has to be SPF 60. so every now
and then we'll have the consumer
sunscreen ones and they'll say Oh look
The sunscreen actually was only 40 or
was 45 or even 30. personally as a
health promoter I don't mind as long as
it's above 30.
and you're reapplying every two hours
because no matter what the SPF is even
if it's 50 or higher you still have to
reapply every two hours so like the the
lab
use of it compared to real life use
um so I'm not that worried about people
using ones that haven't met the label
but obviously they should yeah
and the last question is the issue of um
just promoting some risk areas so um
some what sorry some risk areas risk
areas so I've had two three three lots
of uh melanoma in recent times and one
of the ones that really surprised me was
the back of my hand and they said that a
lot of truck drivers do that they just
drive like that they slap everyone else
don't worry about the hands because our
hands are exposed all the time we should
have on the dashboard in the sun all day
and every day and that's how I got mine
so I'm sorry no no not to be sorry just
sometimes we don't know the risks that
we're facing towards too late well and
it's that thing where it adds up every
day and that's the thing is like our
hands are literally out and about every
day
um so yeah it's definitely worth
thinking about them people who are
outside driving and stuff like that we
used to wear gloves back in the days
probably not a bad idea well that's what
they're suggesting with the truck
drivers they should wear the fingerless
Club yeah yep thank you councilor Bond
okay thank you Bridget for your um
attendance today in educating us about
um the concerns of the Cancer Society
one of the things I'm interested in
knowing is you've identified the sun
shades
um that could help prevent actually UV
eye protection especially throughout
times of the years so we know that a lot
of our primary schools at the moment are
looking after the the children in that
way what's your view in terms of
um shade or sun shades in our streets
are you asking the council to take a
lead there and provide that for all of
our community members I mean if you like
if you're doing a new build and there's
an opportunity to make sure there is
some shade there available I I would
need to get better and like better
advice the architectural sort of side of
it because I don't know all the details
but I suspect that actually you'd want
something a physical structure rather
than one of the shades that is like one
of the ones you put up and take down
um they they're great but they they do
need a bit of Maintenance to look after
them particularly with wind and stuff so
if you're doing any builds I think it'd
be good if there was sort of
how do you say like hard you know like
physical shade and you can get shade
that still lets the heat through but
doesn't let the UV through
um but yeah I definitely
get some really good advice around there
and I can put you in touch with
where you get that sort of advice from
but it would be great if like the
playgrounds had some good shade
available and yeah and the thing here is
that you might want shade from Sun but
you might also want shade from rain so
it can sort of multitask
Bridget thanks for coming along you'll
be interested to know that our senior
Park staff are here oh yeah and have
heard what you have to say and um
particularly in around health and safety
for their staff I know that they do
provide and offer good advice around
being Sun smart and know they also
Advocate strongly for the use of EVS as
you acknowledged so messages have been
heard Bridget thanks very much for
coming along a timely visit from you
thank you yeah yeah I know
I'll tell you to
thank you and yeah I'll be emailing that
stuff and I'm very happy to email it to
you too as well um if I can get the
email addresses are they on the website
um if they if they come into us at
Council um staff will disseminate them
across everyone for you cool cool that
sounds fabulous and yeah happy for
people to get in touch with me for
further questions and I can try to find
out answers if I don't know thank you so
much for having me thank you thanks
Bridget
Kai Collective welcome along
[Music]
welcome Rochelle
uh dear nikoto uh thank you for the
opportunity to present to you today
about
um our Mahi to create a good food
roadmap for murihiku Kauai ho uh
call Rachelle Francis
so I'm Rochelle I work for Healthy
Families invercargill we are very much
um like Bridget's presentation around
um you know altering our environments to
support health because that's all our KO
papa is really about
um and so I support the facilitation of
the medihiku kai Collective this is Dr
Anna palacer who is a tutor at sit and a
member of our Collective
so is there a PowerPoint
um coming
so in August this year we facilitated a
one-day co-design workshop with around
70 participants from across murihiku
Southland are these people included
manafinoa local food producers in
suppliers kopapa Maori initiatives
Social and Health agencies including
Maori and Pacifica organizations and
food relief people working in education
social Enterprise sat Environmental
Management tutors and students Community
organizations volunteers Coin South
elected local government representatives
and MP local and Regional Council staff
Garden to table and people with lived
experience of food poverty so as you can
see quite a range of participants and
we're up to slide three now thank you
yeah so we utilize the good food roadmap
strategic framework which was developed
by Healthy Families South Auckland and
the southern initiative and is now being
adopted in various parts of aotearoa
interestingly recently it's been adopted
by a range of local boards in the
Auckland area so I've printed copy of
this framework which will circulate
around the group
and this framework helped to guide our
Corridor by defining our desired future
state in five areas of focus
so in the ALCO design Workshop we began
asking people to share their vision for
medihiku's food system some key things
emerged which in essence were that
participants want food to be affordable
and accessible to our whole Community
while supporting the health of people
and planet and sustaining a strong local
economy which is a vision that I'm sure
we can all ascribe to
yeah
so participants spent some time
exploring the burning issues and it was
clear that our community is very
concerned about how difficult it is for
people to access good food and believe
action is needed to address problems in
our food system
the burning issues that came through
included poor access and affordability
of good food versus unhealthy fast food
options food waste a lack of diversity
and locally grown foods and the need for
more Growers Reliance on National and
international food chains and the local
food system trying to compete with the
supermarket duopoly issues around land
use water soil health and escalating
impacts of climate change lack of
regional strategy and Collective
approach to addressing the root causes
foreign
so then we gathered participants around
the five ideals and the good food
roadmap which are food Equity food
sovereignty food culture and traditions
food for health and well-being and food
resilience and the beauty of using this
framework is that everyone's able to
locate themselves inside these five
ideals they can see how their particular
area of Interest connects with the broad
vision of the flourishing local food
system and also each of these five
ideals needs to be worked towards in
tandem with one another as part of an
overarching strategy and action plan if
we're to achieve our big picture goal
so in our breakout groups around these
five ideals our community members
identified a range of strengths and
challenges that exist in our community
and they also identified oh sorry
resources and challenges that's what I
said thank you please keep going all
right
um and then this was where the really
exciting part of the workshop happened
so we dedicated a focus time for
participants to ask how might we how
might we utilize these resources and
address these challenges a range of
ideas were put forward and here is a
selection of them
um just noting that they're still at
Rough concept stage
so one group I refined their idea for a
regional Chi coordinator similar roles
exist in parts of New Zealand often
sitting within Council or supported by
Council and they help to connect and
facilitate collaboration of people
working inside the food system this role
was conceptualized as reporting to the
murihiku kai Collective
another idea put forward was
um
next slide please
um was by Zeb horal from riversdale to
convert underutilized public spaces into
permanent food production and while this
isn't a new idea
um there was some very interesting new
Innovative methods and approaches that
he suggested which most significantly
are already being trialled in the
riversdale area
next one ah Community Food Hub so food
hubs are being used nationally and
internationally to ruin the great Local
Food Systems utilizing economies of cell
to help alleviate challenges that
small-scale producers commonly face and
work on a principle of collaboration
rather than competition
so you can see that our community really
does hold the answers to rejuvenating
our local food system and it's an
absolute privilege to work with them in
this bold Endeavor we will continue to
gather together to co-create original
strategy and action plan and we would so
appreciate your continued support and
participation and that's but for now we
just wanted to update you and provide
some uplifting news and food for thought
to take into the holiday period
um and myself and Anna are both able to
answer any questions you have counter
Michelle papania then Tom
my do you want to pull that microphone
in please
you may it may have been been aware
about that he had type program that used
to run a number of years ago happy
eating healthy action and a lot of um
communities drove that really extremely
well with Community Gardens and a lot of
them still exist unfortunately
government talk about the pundit so my I
really want to say this is really good
and it's really good that you've got a
good Community Drive behind it and
things like that but
uh where I was sort of going as like how
you know how we sort of build on those
sort of like ideas and initiatives but
how do we actually
um
support whanau to actually grow their
own
rather than creating dependency
you know creating Independence uh the
other thing I want to say is that I said
there was a lot of initiatives going up
around communities in regards to stores
where people just drop off their you
know extra things in the garden and they
Facebook each you know groups and I hear
that's working extremely well so I just
want to hear you build on things that
exist
at work
yeah that's a great question and so
um we didn't share all of the um ideas
that came forward but there were ideas
that were um building on existing models
that exist in our community around
providing wraparounds to support to
whanau and Nate
um a really great model an example of
that is Spirit Army locally who are
moving people away from dependency and
and to
um you know being able to be
self-reliant and then give back to the
community so
um I guess um the muriheko kai
Collective we're wanting to provide
um space and support to be able to
develop these initiatives and and ensure
they're resourced and support them to be
successful in the community
um so yeah those those things that you
talked about are definitely things that
we discuss
um and our Hui that we're mindful of and
I'd love to share with you in more
detail
um like specifics of things that we're
involved in and one significant project
as the timada project which is starting
in the Aurora College grounds which is
really about helping whanau to become
um you know build self-efficacy yeah I
know that sounds fantastic
did you think of anything
apparently just try and restrict it to
questions
I'm going to build off the okay how you
consider taking home those weed plants
you know thank you Tom
I I wonder how you would dispel a you
know kind of economic model that I have
which as that as through the say the
18th and 19th century as communities
moved from you know small local
production grown things in their Garden
to you know to agricultural industrial
production people became better fed
became wealthier because it just became
cheaper to produce uh you know a unit of
um a calorie than it was under the
previous system now you know you're
advocating I think you know kind of
return to that previous model
um but doesn't it kept flying if it's a
history
it's not actually a return
um because it's incorporating
new technology as well right so
um and it and we're not like
Reinventing a wheel that's already been
spinning and being discarded because all
over the place particularly in the
United States at the moment
there's this these new initiatives to
localize food resilience
because there's a recognition that this
big agricultural machine that you're
talking about that provides cheap food
has got two big flaws in it and one is
that it's beginning to crumble with the
with the crumbling of the cat the way
that the global economic system is going
along with climate change means that
that system may not be able to sustain
for very much longer like some of the
big food baskets in the US that produce
this cheap food are not going to be able
to produce food for very much longer in
the same way so that's one thing that
the big global system is now hitting a
lot of snails
and the other thing is that with some of
the new technologies some of these local
food
places that are really beginning to make
millions of dollars for the local food
economies in various U.S cities
are actually using things like
um
you know great big greenhouses that are
producing food on scale but are doing it
locally and generating local jobs so
it's not just going back to backyard
gardening
it's bringing in new ideas new ideas
about technology but also about
collaboration like Michelle was saying
and spinning a different wheel
to build local food resilience which is
improving local economies across the US
particularly in poorer areas but is also
providing some security against
the collapse of the the
um
less productive nature of the global
food economy so it's not like just going
backwards in time at all and you may
have noticed Anna knows quite a lot
about this as she teaches the food
papers at Southern Institute of
Technology that are offered in the
Environmental Management
distributed
America
and what if I saw it happening
yeah I I wasn't really arguing the
converse I just wanted to hear your
response to that so appreciate that
thank you thank you thanks Rachelle and
Anna for taking the time to come sorry
I've gone over time
um yes thank you so much for um for
listening to our presentation can I get
someone to hand these or would you just
like me to send them around the
um the good food roadmap yeah
us have they already been provided yes
it's amazing oh this is um this is the
full version which has um which has
explanation of the model
um in the back so provides the whole
detail oh thank you thank you so much
thanks councilors that brings us to the
first item on the agenda which is the
2022 annual report
of the invercargill city youth Council
the recommendation is that the committee
receives the report
in the absence of any of the youth
councilors being present it is
worth noting that both councilor
crackett and I have been attending their
meetings this year and
um although no appointee for the last
two I think
but it is worth noting in there that
um Ollie morkinson who's provided
service to the youth Council since 2013
is finishing in that role he's helped
run the youth Council along with Jimmy
Crawford
and has been there and seen many uh
tremendously inspirational young adults
who are now back and working in the
community and we're certainly grateful
for the time that he's dedicated to us
so the recommendation is that the um
report is received councilor crickets
moving are you on the committee sorry
yes
Technologies and uh seconded by Reverend
cook any questions
are you aware of the Jr McKinsey trust
for uniforms
are you aware of the Jr McKenzie are
they aware of the J.R McKenzie trust for
uniforms
right because they are available and
they talk about supporting students oh
and so that that's available to any
student who needs it right
so the schools are aware of that yes
schools should be aware of it not all of
them they quite often need to be pushed
to say access it but many of the rotary
clubs are supported as well or make them
aware of it yeah I can give you a
context that'd be great
any other questions
if not I'll put the motion in all in
favor I Against
Kerry brings us to the minutes of the
committee meeting back on Tuesday
November the 15th somebody like to move
30 minutes
Mr coote
what that all in favor
aye against carried
uh that brings us to the Sandy Point
master plan
and
then
like a blunt Caroline
good afternoon
um so what you've got in front of you is
a report just to recap the purpose of
the Sandy Point domain master plan
project was to establish a long-term
plan for the future of the park use the
asset renewal and the developments and
help us guide future funding decisions
the work we've undertaken today includes
site analysis stakeholder and public
engagement and then we've done the
collation in the review of the available
technical information
um and some establishment of some design
principles and the key moves
unfortunately there's a delay in the
technical data that we've been awaiting
so it's predominantly the lidar data but
we are also awaiting um an appetite hono
um analysis done by natar hotel marama
and an economic analysis and then that
lidar data so because of the delay there
we're actually recommending that we
pause on the master planning for now and
re-engage when that data is available
thank you any questions counselors
hey Clark yeah on on post uh 20 of board
books but on page um five of your report
Caroline it talks about
um
possible changes to access and use of
the reserve could impact the rights and
freedoms of residents importantly the
stakeholders with police so that's
Cooper's Creek
are you in a position to expand on what
that actually means because over on the
next page it it talks again about
Under The Heading leases stakeholders
with leases or a license to occupy will
need to have documentation restructured
until the management plan has been
adopted now it's it's no secret to
anybody around this table that we've got
ongoing issues with the leaseholders out
there
um so
um mechlight that's why we've identified
it in the legal implications because we
are aware there are some issues there
but as the master plan is not complete
yet predetermined the outcome would be
ill-informed we're just basically noting
in these legal implications that there
will be some
um until the master plan is complete
they aren't in effect
at the moment we've just got a delay so
we're delaying a request that we have to
Freehold land and also with the master
plan the management plan the current
management plan it expiring as it were
um we're delaying the review of that
so that's where the legal implications
coming on with all of the leases and the
licenses to occupy relate to the
management plan of 2012. which we should
be reviewing next year because we're not
we would like to notify them that
there's a
slight change in the management plan
process
happy with the slide change I guess just
want to have some confidence I guess
that we've had this ongoing dispute with
him over there yeah recent increase to
their
license holding situations that this is
not some sort of attempt to sort of
override that unresolved issue
absolutely not no it's okay thank you
thank you Reverend cook
so that's where you Mr chair to um
strain
given that some of the areas
that we may be discussing are going to
be or are already being affected by
climate change I am
guessing that the lidar is really
critical about that yes we do feel that
it is Reverend cook
yeah so in terms of the total amount of
space
at 70 point have we got
any rough idea of how much of it is
going to be impacted
within the next 10 years of the plan by
climate change no we haven't that's why
we want to complete all of that
technical data so that we can make those
informed decisions and make our
management plan as informed as possible
for the next 10 years the master plan to
recap is for hopefully 50 years so what
a 50-year plan of the land will look
like but a management plan which may
start to address or may have to start
addressing some climate change issues at
least for the next 10 years and does
that include
the types of re-vegetation that may be
required yes thank you yes ringing
my question follows on about sea level
rise but
Dewey does our Council have reliable
accurate
information that will guide us on the on
the sea level rise okay or do we Google
it or what how do we work it out do we
actually put some science behind it
obviously because you know it's quite
critical
that's what this report is all about is
actually putting some science behind all
of the information we have so
um with all the stakeholders we've
worked with on this we've told them that
any master plan will be based on as
evidence-based as we can so that's why
we want to understand that lidar data so
that we can put that alongside the niwa
data and all of the other evidence that
is out there to make the most informed
decision possible okay so
now for consistency this information
that we're doing for Sandy Point is it
going to flow through into the rest of
councils District plans and all our
everything that we do that actually has
touches on the effects of seeing level
rise instead it's a really good question
and that lidar data has actually been
commissioned by environment Southland
and when it's available to them say well
I'm sure
um obviously distribute it throughout
all of the councils in in the Southland
area so that more more informed
decisions can be made throughout yeah
because the reason for consistency is
that obviously you know you don't you
don't want different roles for different
uh the various different planes we have
yeah understood yeah thanks so good to
know there's a regional approach being
taken I guess it's probably particularly
pertinent for Sandy Point since it's the
lowest lying part of the city
or close to it if not to the lowest
anyway
Barry
yeah have you sir I believe there used
to be a ranger
look after Sandy Point
is that being looked at again
because of all the anti-social
good question that goes on down there
not as part of the master plan that
perhaps would be something that would
come up through the management plan once
we've actually got the the long-term
plan for the uh space to be
um visualized
it's not part of this immediate process
I just believed it worked last time and
then he disappeared
and now there's all sorts of anti-social
things going on down there with cars
getting into another and burning them
out
yeah and just to kind of touch point off
Bear's comment and the long term plan or
the master plan have there been
considerations for CCTV
um to go out Sandy Point to cover areas
that are high risk
um there is CCTV planned for Sunny Point
already
um outside of this process
thank you thanks
thanks Tom
when you talk about the you know the
need for the the lidar data which I know
has been coming for a long time hasn't
it
um the obviously the other question is
you know how much sea level will rise
and there's a range involved in that my
question is that when I look at you know
a whole lot of
initiatives and I'm going to say around
Southland rather than only in
invercargill
um as the a common assumption about that
because because of everybody's assuming
different things you know we assumed a
different thing for Sandy Point then we
may assume for some other part uh South
under even invercargill then you know
that seems counterintuitive so Mike
maybe you don't know the answer actually
but my question was whether it's a
common view about what we assume to be
the
um
you know sea level rise rather than just
a broad range which
I don't hold a common view unfortunately
counts with Campbell yeah I can't answer
that question for you
me Clark just one quick thing Caroline
about the um about the potential for the
Ranger with you citizen the management
plan as opposed to the master plan
um just to give you some feedback that
um obviously I'll live out there as you
as you know
um and certainly the range of winning
was there did a lot of work around the
anti-social Behavior which has
significantly increased since then I
guess it's costing a city to repair and
to put in
um vegetation that discourages that but
he also do quite a bit of educational
work as well
and also the ranger managed the aridi
beach access area which at the moment
tends to be that we just graded if and
when we get a lot of complaints we have
a routine for doing it but if it gets
too much where the ranger could actually
signal and master that look I'm getting
cast I can hear all cars are being burnt
out or whatever they're just I guess I'm
just signaling with it so so we have
helpful to be considering that yeah
Clark we have Rangers at Sandy Point
every day and every day they do check
that bakes at beach access and they do
put in a request for service to our
infrastructure team as and when it's
required when they do notice cars
getting difficulty so the the
non-residents of a ranger out there
shouldn't impact on that at the moment
thank you they're not further questions
they're uh three
um recommendations one that is received
by the committee and this two
recommendations to council councilor
Boyle you moving yes thank you seconded
by Council
is there are no further questions I'll
put the motion all in favor
aye aye against
Kerry thank you black Caroline
which brings us to the activities report
of the minister of dreams and sparkles
take his rightful position
thank you Mr chair
um look I'll start off with the summary
before I pass the treaty
um so a couple of highlights I guess the
summary of the Leisure and Recreation
portfolio reporters
continued recovery
um
um our community's engagement with our
services and it's really positive to see
and that's off the back of stable
delivery and stable platform of policy
changes so we're really grateful and the
teams are really happy to be busy
coupler key points I'd like to note is I
think is really great around the
improved performance with our Splash
Palace as retail and Cafe area
and
whilst it's not a naturally assumed fit
with a community service what it does
show is we're actually giving our
community what they want when they need
it which I actually think is what any
service should be doing
better products and better Goods so it
is great to see that that's being now
reflected and then the take up on that
part of our service
the progress on our collection with the
museum service I think is really
positive both with the packing the
accessioning and the de-accessioning
work and in particular the work on
finalizing that collections policy which
is the key enabler for all of that
I guess the other pleasing thing is that
Council took the move to move to fines
free on July 1 and the positive response
the numbers seem to be suggesting that
it is doing what most other libraries
around the country in the world have
shown that you remove the fines and you
see greater uptake and that's the same
here too which I think is great for our
community
and ultimately
I think the really great messages that
the vast and different ways in which our
team are engaging with the community
both in delivery of services and running
our facilities and providing spaces I
think it's great to see the degree in
which we're getting out there and
working with people to do our Mahi so
happy to take any questions where I've
passed a treaty to talk to her points
thanks Steve almost tongue-in-cheek a
little bit I was really intrigued to see
the effect that the removal of fines had
on book returns to the library but I'm
hugely anecdotally confident that same
would not work with parking
um
I'll pull my tongue out of my cheek now
with the upturn in Cafe activity at
Splash Palace does that also coincide
with the introduction of the new Hydro
slides we're bringing more people in and
giving them more reason to stay no
um because we I think we had a cafe
there before the Hydra slides and what
we have done is our team have really put
the customer at the heart of our
decision making around how we provide
our services what we provide in our
service and how we communicate the
services to the people who use our
facilities and so you'll see that
actually our participations have gone up
and we're getting more people buying
products but but there's also that other
unique Factor where
people are actually spending more with
us because the products there for them
because and you see that when you when
we go to the pool you do actually see
people sitting in the in the cafe more
sitting down with their friends and
having a yank and it is that sort of
social element that our community
facilities bring to our community they
are hubs we're people meet
thanks Steve any other questions for
Steve before I go to treaty uh Nobby
then Tom yeah two things Steve
um with the cafe Splash Palace we I
think we've had both private sector
running there and our own staff
being mindful that not trying to
compromise you for the museum going
forward
but what's your view on on stop running
a cafe
given they have other duties of weather
um
it would be better run by private sector
I think each have a mere Clark I think
each have a place
um and
what we've done at Splash plus is
through the nature of the design of the
facility we've got one reception counter
and what the team have done over the
last 18 months is we've we had gone
through a change process where we've
taken two teams and merged them into one
so that we can be incredibly efficient
with our with our team delivering that
service and it has provided benefit both
to our reception area and to our Cafe
area and so that is one of the benefits
of Staff running it as you don't have
that separation of of service which
means that we can
deal with both issues depending on which
county you turn up you don't need to
just
talk about the cafe if you're there you
can actually ask about swimming lessons
and it is one of the benefits can I give
a historical context about the museum as
well it was a lease operation up until a
time when the leaseholder fell over not
physically but in a financial sense and
because the Redevelopment project was on
the horizon
um it wasn't thought we'd lease it out
but there was a strong desire to see the
the service continue
Tom
uh could I maybe refer you to page 35 of
diligent
um and the chart that's headed animal
control
and just for some clarification
we'll come to that yeah so it's just the
post libraries oh you're only talking
about kill my library at the moment yeah
sorry there's
two different offices reporting oh okay
yeah I'll come back to it right nothing
still had two issues to stay my apology
um so in the collection one on page 42
aboard books it talks about the
collection being approximately 45
million objects and if I keep getting
these figures tossed around from Two and
a half million to four and a half
million I mean
are we sure about that or was it still a
moving Feast for us just helpful to know
what the volume is yes okay you're right
you have seen a number of figures it is
it is that four and a half million
figure
um
we do and I guess this is one of the
benefits of really digging into what is
in the museum as we asked we are seeing
the volume come through sure
okay
um and the other issue is just to give
you some feedback on Lloyd essler which
is on page 51 who did a bit of a tour
around the graveyards and one have you
um I got some really good feedback about
it my partner when she's sort of really
interesting and you can see in the
pictures there you've got some young
people there as well they're quite
interested in some other Graves
um so that's I guess some of the ways
that we might enhance our city because
some of the feedback we got from the 18
to 30 year olds is they wanted more
one-off things that they could actually
attempt to that worked out really well
thanks any other questions for Steve
truly to you
yeah three year Mr chair so uh some
consistent results again from the
consenting areas and areas such as limbs
uh you'll see the average time for limb
delivery has on average decreased which
is a positive for our customers there's
also some
uh information for you around work the
communications team did over October and
I'm happy to take any questions
thank you sir Tom
apologies thank you
um so pitch 36 of board books and the
chart that's headed animal control just
for clarification from me the the sub
dot point the
um explanation says impairments were
similar to October 2021 an old dogs were
returned to their owners but when I look
at October 2021 it says 16 dogs went and
pounded and 16 dogs were returned when I
look at October 2022 it says 35 dogs
were impounded and no dogs were returned
that's right I've just noticed this as
well so I will um come have to come back
to you from the staff they'll be
watching this and hopefully they will be
emailing me
foreign
[Music]
bullet point one it says following up on
unreasoned dogs has resulted in 108 dogs
rested in October not the top as it says
78.
yeah yes
I will have to come back to you I think
they may have slipped through last
month's commentary and it got through
was an important issue though without
being flippant because we have had some
issues raised about
what we do with dogs that we potentially
can't find the owners that'd be helpful
to know that we've returned or rehomed
yeah thank you
of course it's always really easy with
good dog owners that notice their
animals are missing get in touch yeah
um it's always a really useful first
step of course for those dogs that don't
get as far as the film when the Animal
Control Officers find them on the side
and can scan them and see where they
belong they quite often just go and drop
them off there which is a big change in
the level of service with then we
provided a few years ago which wasn't
taken straight to the pound yeah
thank you for that any other questions
for that part of it
if not would somebody like to move that
the activities report is received moved
me a classic to Tom
there are no questions or comments I'll
put that all in favor against
carried cancers that brings us to the
end of the committee there's nothing set
down for uh in committee so I'll close
the meeting and thank you for a dentist
and if you could just hang around for a
couple of minutes I think the mayor has
a couple of things he wants to update us
on thanks to the members of public
who've joined us on the live stream
meeting us closed